welcome to this video playing a 15
minute game against mmm Lars are real
ODT this right lazzara do I always have
problems telling l and I support is this
lateral order I as a rule oh okay oh
it's got a very very fresh 15 minute
rating here so you can see you it's just
two game so the rating is a bit inflated
it seems comparing to some 5 million
rating yeah as regularly observed them
playing strength of the opponents in the
15 million games assume sometimes in
comparison relatively low to the
five-minute games simply far less
players interested in playing longer
time controls there is also a 45-minute
format here on the ISS see which I tried
out as well the problem there is that
you barely get any opposition in
15-minute games it's um it's a bit
easier but still you have many very
uneven sorry uneven match ups so I like
to do them do the games in this time
control they provide them more insight
so have simply a bit more time to talk
about various things don't British but
what the heck is he doing here never
seen Queen d4 it's not such a such an
unusual move not quite sure about the
name of the salon I guess it has a name
I think someone wrote to me much earlier
Matt's a month ago this is called the
check over variation
okay a six yeah this is one of the
theoretical main lines one point being
that knight c6 would have been answered
by Bishop b5 not a problem for black but
he is just preparing this move he wants
to win a real temper on the Queen there
is c4 here is one move however Carson
had played h3 here which have tried out
before maybe not on video but I think I
tried it and no you know correspondence
some style game on chess calm the moose
h3 has some very interesting idea
instead of h3 bite here in this position
very often go see for setting up the
maroc see bind but he wants to avoid
that black is able to play Bishop g4 and
exchange the bishop for the night and
this is why h3 is first played so that
Bishop g4 is not possible my plan is
that basically whatever black is doing
yeah like this i'm going to play c4 and
set up the maroc see bind yeah let's do
this it's always a bit weird with those
Queen moves but it's not it's not a big
deal really the queen is not terribly
badly placed on e3 it cannot be hit by a
piece for example of course you cannot
do yeah in any way refute blacks play
with this type of opening the certainly
wasn't Carlton's intention when he
played this against the given Jones and
the London chess classics i think it was
in 2012 yeah maybe they had exactly this
position if not it is really close yeah
the Queen only three it blocks the
bishop from c1 but very often pt3 Bishop
b2 is a good idea anyway so
or let's say it is a valid to set up um
what I need to be aware of if i play b 3
let's say black plays Bishop d7 em some
move like that Fargo be three there
might be night XD form very typical a
technical idea exploiting the weakness
of this long diagonal so maybe I need to
play a further preparation move for
example something like rook to be one
and only then be three that it's not a
bad move anyway rugby one the bishop
won't be too even if I could play b3
Bishop b2 it's very often helpful to
have the bishop protected so that the
further 95 is some supported yeah I
think I'll go go with that or let's
briefly check yeah I think it makes
sense anyway in this move the problem
that black faces in a way in this
particular form of the maroc see binders
with this Queen D for Queen III thing
there is no knight on d4 and very often
black some typical setup involves a
night trade training nights on d4 it's
happening very often in the maroc see so
that after the nights are of the board
you actually gain this is six in the six
square for your bishop so that you can
after the nitrate play Bishop d7 to see
six maybe a 597 to c5 black Lexus space
here in the maroc see bind and it like
to trade one or two pieces this is also
why h3 is played yeah making sure that
Bishop g4 is not helping black 22 to
reduce the pressure okay let's see um
not quite sure what blacks idea is not
this with 97 yeah you can
course um try to go to c5 but it is a
pretty it is not a very stable position
for the nighttime can hit it with B form
Queen B 6am does this could this is a
possibility that in between be successes
idea hmm yeah but that's not really
going to helping heaven much what I
wonder is should I play be 3 or should I
even play before him could be M could be
just the more more active move yeah but
why not actually just them controlling
the c5 square well night c5 wasn't a
threat but if you can expand here why
not if he goes Queen B 6 here i'll just
play Queen d2 I think this was my idea
at least hitting him with 95 later and
then Bishop e2
yeah yeah black could try an ID to e5
actually this could be an IBM term to
trade one of the nights yeah this is in
fact an idea that I like 92 you five
yeah probably route you one then is a
good idea okay it tries to trade Queen's
gym the question is some some other
square that D 2 D 2 looks like the most
the most obvious scram I can also play
95 if it's not not totally crazy but it
would somewhat speed up my development
yep Queen takes we should take but a
queen trait is normally helping black
iam as mentioned he has less space and
you welcome trade if you suffer from
space disadvantage yeah of course it
cannot take on B form there's not d 5 or
a three winning the piece that if I
probably been the easiest
yeah that's yeah I thought you should
have played that without queen bee six
but ok that's of course a very tempting
move yeah 95 and maybe just we should be
two after that okay let's let's do it
okay never take now only five there is
also the move d takes if I have to
consider giving him a very nice outpost
on deform I don't really want to allow
that yeah I rather play Bishop e2
because II six I can drop back to e3 as
well
this position isn't isn't totally
terrible for black I mean I prefer white
simply because um I like to have a space
advantage very much but but don't think
is in absolutely terrible shape there
should be six for example still looks
very viable okay okay maybe you can play
yeah maybe can do that taking on be too
yeah let's say Bishop b2 Queen B 2 and
then maybe five attending 90 form
yeah okay just be sure between less no
no real no real reason to spend time on
this so he went for an entirely entirely
different approach so I move like f4 I
would just take on c4 IM
yeah okay this is probably repeating
this probably needs to be played in any
way in any in any case I wonder if F for
years it's interesting I i think i
should try to play aggressively in the
center yeah where's he going I mean
knight c6 there is some this I can take
a play Quincy three winning a peace out
he probably needs to go to d7 em yeah I
think if he go needs to go to the seven
then f-4s birth plane I'm not planning a
king side attack but I just want to
control those squares arrived in
particular yeah yeah thought actually
that I'm winning the sea porn am I not
ok I can take ke he can take on be to
himself but still
yeah if he takes here I take on g7 Queen
defund Quincy for winning the spawn so
it probably has to do that and now Luke
takes or queen takes rook takes probably
am Brooke checks I guess and now yeah
yet now probably queen deform preventing
e6 because of Knight d4 I wonder I also
can't play f5 f5 is also a move
hmm yeah five maybe we should be 70 just
taking this night no matter what the
other alternative is Queen D forward
with that essentially is winning a pawn
I mean let's do that come on um I don't
see how he how he keeps the c-4 born
here maybe Bishop a6 covering it for the
moment threatening c3 but if I play
something learn that group c 1 and a
form I mean I don't think you can keep
the pawn yeah well now I can take it
yeah and I think I should really at
least a half to that I have a pretty
prickly a winning idea to worm protected
patter 22 passes a and B born now there
is no particular counter play
and note that here I took with the with
the rukon be too not with the Queen
because I wanted to put the Queen on d4
anyway so rook takes me to basically one
a temple so we take or took on d5 here I
came know how do you take it yeah with
the porn huh this might become a
weakness the d5 pawn the seems seems
easy on check it wasn't totally clear
cut taking with the pawn also had the
merits because the seven pawn then is
much easier to attack oh I wonder about
f5 p.m. he has no moved to a check mark
pieces right yeah let's do that at five
after ook f8 especially this move is
interesting
okay so it's taking my Rukia on everyone
unfortunately really know nothing to
take here for example f1 protects f7
okay so we have this straight which is
not a big deal i mean i have to
protected passes protected connected
connected passes so should I just push
the pawns yeah probably first I get rid
of this this week pawn yeah now I can't
play a 4 and b5 just giving up you form
yeah it should win it's a matter of
timing i'm just too quick he will get he
will get with rookie if I if I will get
the pawn but I would just be be too
quick with the with the beep on so move
it now b6 okay for b7 rugby a truck see
one end and over yeah yeah probably
also look a one was possible and then
and then pushing the pawns now with the
rook on the second rank he also has no
last hope count to play with rooks on
the second rank or something oh did I
miss something thought this was pretty
clear-cut yeah i think it is roxy ages
with a check so or like this giving
winning the the rook basically with ruby
70 it should be some continuing that
let's um let's see
we are probably switching to an attack
from the from the frontier now I'm
threatening look everyone winning one of
those pawns that's not yeah this is the
way to play against that jab but still a
rook is a rookie the rook black resigns
yeah it's really a bit pointless if the
opponent has got six minutes on the
clock okay so let's think about about
this amount about Iran tiered looked
very normal I think white is comfortable
but it shouldn't be anything out of the
ordinary so Ruby one was designed to
prepare be three but also maybe before
and after 97 I felt tempted to go for B
form yeah and yeah this is in fact a
point the computer now points out the
move that that I am actually had
mentioned in the game this night de5
move the serve is probably a bit better
the idea is that Here I am have trouble
to avoid a piece trade and if I take
myself then the this move becomes very
interesting using the d4 square I
probably after this play something like
rook d1 and it's quite similar to the
game but note that this yeah since the
Queen back end I'm sort of have everyone
one or two museum just briefly the
computer him once to play this move
which I had discarded because I didn't
want to trade I mean is it really that
bad
the comp capsule gives wide a pretty
substantial advantage stock Fisher's the
engine i'm using here mmm Chuck I'm not
sure I mean what it's certainly not
worse that's clear but normally you
don't want to trade queens or trade any
any piece that if you don't don't
necessarily need to in the maracas see
because of your space advantage and does
still feel that this should be
relatively ok check for black I mean
yeah this is this i don't like I think
black should really consider this and
putting the knight on d4 this isn't just
just a playable position for black with
no big problems something like this
might be an idea so that this becomes a
possibility that's pretty good for white
actually so it probably shouldn't play
94 immediately and go for something like
that yeah and that's just a playable
position 90m I think the weaknesses
start to tell ya here rook takes us
better than Queen takes as I want to go
to d4 anyway yeah TM black basically
loses the pawn this is not really
helping helping much I know and this was
my IDM computer plays rook c2
it wants to take on c4 with the BB rook
is this person anyway not much we should
be five ya hear us thought this one was
good compounds to play a 4 with the big
edge yeah a for Bishop takes rook c4 and
then Luke c7 probably coming yeah why
this white is really just better here in
various ways yeah here it takes is also
ok check gathers invites f5 really
that's I think beyond saving the two
points of our two much here and here
well i think what i did is this is
totally sufficient ta are probably
looked to be seven but the two grants
available will decide here he cannot
really avoid avoid the loss of this book
so when he could have put up a tougher
defense around around TM probably the
immediate not d35 is the the best way to
get a get a decent position alright
thanks for watching